c'était pas trop raciste ça
c'est juste un petit peu en dessous des
vannes sur les Roumains
[Applaudissements]
alors avant de démarrer petite mise au
point l'humour noir c'est mon Gagnepain
et donc je demanderai à Nico saliagas
qui l'autre soir a annoncé Grégory
Lemarchal en direct live à la télé de ne
pas me piquer mon boulot voilà moi je
cherche pas à être le plus con du PAF et
à m'habiller comme un cake je respecte
le travail des autres
excusez-moi Thierry hein
et on démarre avec du cinéma et la
sortie de Mission Impossible 4
bonjour agence Sarkozy votre mission si
vous l'acceptez sera de délivrer cet
otage au Tchad votre contact
Idriss débite attention il y a un piège
les quatre têtes espagnoles sont
habillés comme des vendeuses de chez
Darty
ramenez les directs en Espagne évitez la
France Brice Hortefeux les attend avec
un test ADN aller-retour dans la journée
vous êtes divorcé nous sommes dimanche
ça vous évitera de vous faire chier good
luck
[Applaudissements]
atteint d'hyperactivité Nicolas Sarkozy
prodige sans arrêt des conseils l'autre
jour chez Mohamed VI il indiquait à la
princesse comment isoler un plafond
jamais en reste Mohamed lui a appris
comment tenir son épouse avec un
poignard
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas trop raciste ça
c'est juste un petit peu en dessous des
vannes sur les Roumains
allez-y merci
trop dilettante l'emploi du temps
présidentiel va s'étoffer voici un
programme type midi salon de
l'agriculture 12h30 l'Alpe d'Huez avec
Michel Drucker 13h discussions avec des
marins bretons viens ici si tu as des
couilles 13h30 fête de la saucisse à
Strasbourg 15h marathon de Paris 15h30
marathon de New York le président reste
en basket c'est jouable
[Applaudissements]
l'hyperactivité une maladie grave ce
weekend le président voulait réparer
lui-même les panneaux solaires de la
station spatiale
[Rires]
Christine Lagarde nous donne un conseil
comme roulez moins cette semaine son
conseil quand il pleut trouver quelqu'un
pour tenir votre parapluie
30 clandestins indiens découvert dans
une camionnette c'est encore un conseil
de Christine pour économiser le
carburant privilégier le covoiturage
merci de tester
Rachida Dati candidate dans le 7e cuir
bottes noires bas résille attention
Bertrand il va falloir être viril
bagarreur impitoyable
[Applaudissements]
sport JO 2008 attention au Mexique qui
actuellement s'entraîne très dur en
natation synchronisée
Dorothée je suis prête pour une nouvelle
carrière
nous non on est on n'est pas on n'est
pas prêt
[Applaudissements]
à quoi ressemblerait Régine si elle
sortait sans maquillage un début de
réponse le visage de Toutankhamon
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est fini pardon un Nikos de
mettre énervé j'ai tellement rêvé cet
été qu'il soit bloqué dans les incendies
en Grèce que j'ai c'est vrai tendance à
le prendre un petit peu en grippe c'est
pas bien à la semaine prochaine et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de
innaharditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu